bonsoir à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france d'abord comment
vous une réaction par rapport à ce qu'on
vient d'évoquer c'est à dire cet
incident cet hélicoptère russe a battu à
la frontière donc avec l'azerbaïdjan est
ce que cela peut avoir des conséquences
sur les combats en cours dans le
haut-karabagh oui certainement ça peut
en avoir bon il faut se méfier de des
proviseurs de provocation l'andros et
alico père a été abattu et à ses lois et
même assez loin de toute zone de combat
ce n'est pas du plus sur le front du
karabagh comme l'a dit votre grand
reporter c'est d'ailleurs de l'autre
côté de l'autre côté de la france et de
l'autre frontières sur le prof frontière
arméno azerbaïdjanaises traits d'une
marine chez van près de la ville de vire
h
je crois qu'il faut faire attention et
attendre les résultats blancs 4 parce
que on peut tout imaginer on peut
imaginer une errants arménienne on peut
imaginer une provocation azerbaïdjanaise
ou pas même à imaginer une provocation
de turc
donc restons prudents là dessus et quel
que soit le résultat évidemment ça peut
décider la russie avoué dans un sens ou
dans un autre
alors sur le front des combats dans le
haut-karabagh précisément le président
azéri ilham alief annonce avoir pris la
ville de choucha tête une ville
stratégique dans le même temps l'armée
ni dément avoir perdu cette bataille
que faut-il en penser alors les herbes
et déjà les entreprises touchent à les
arméniens gâchis
si vous voulez en fait ce qu'il faut en
penser c'est que y'a mon chouchi
manifestement n'a pas été prise il est
clair qu'ils hier des groupes isabelle
jeanne est très proche de la ville ont
pu s'infiltrer dans la ville ont pu
prendre des films et des photos
et c'est ce que voulait le président eev
pouvoir montrer pour le aujourd'hui pour
le 9 9 novembre le jour du drapeau les
arbitres jean que le drapeau
azerbaïdjanais sous l'ère deschamps
choucha où surtout si ça a été fait mais
depuis lors ses troupes ont été chassés
et même sans doute neutraliser ce qu'il
va dire du tout que ça soit terminé
les combats continuent et continuent
d'ailleurs féroce autour de la ville
aujourd'hui même alors tel combat qui
continue de manière féroce ce que vous
dites comment justement faire cesser cet
affrontement
ce qu'il faut bien comprendre c'est que
qque chose que chouchi soient prises ou
pas prise demain que les arméniens
arrive à repousser l'offensive
c'est ce qu'il faut bien que nous
n'allons pas affaire à une guerre les
habitants de shoushi comme ceux des
autres villes qui sont passés j'ai déjà
passé sous le contrôle azerbaïdjanais
par exemple hazebrouck où était
totalement expurgée de leur population
arménienne mais machmouchi même à
stepanakert capital qui est le plus
proche des habitants ont été mises en
sécurité ou ont fui
il faut bien comprendre que ce que nous
avons ce vers quoi nous avons appris
aujourd'hui c'est une épuration ethnique
c'est à dire très simplement là où
l'armée a dit janet progresse et bien
tout simplement il n'ya plus d'arméniens
ils ne reviendront pas parce que
l'azerbaïdjan qui maltraite ses propres
citoyens a produit très ouvertement
c'était pas moi qui le dit c'est le
challenge lui même qui le chassera comme
des chiens tous les arméniens
il ya des crimes de guerre et il ya des
existe des décapitations
donc je pense que le temps n'est plus
aux négociations et je dis ça pour les
médiateurs internationaux s'ils veulent
se rendre utiles aujourd'hui il faut
qu'ils fassent tomber les combats et
pour faire stopper le combat il faut
reconnaître le karabagh parce que c'est
un moyen d'entrer dans un processus
qu'on appelle la sécession remède est
donc de commencer des négociations mais
sans la reconnaissance sans que stylée
médiateurs internationaux ne st pas de
cette fosse comment dire impartialité
qui est non seulement stérile si
aujourd'hui est mortifère eh bien rien
s'arrêtera parce que les arméniens ne
s'interrompt pas de combattre parce que
pour eux c'est soit combattre sur mourir
c'est très simple et l'azerbaïdjan et
bientôt comparaître à pois continuera
alors laurent est là il gagne on vient
d'avoir cette information la léraba de
gens qui s'excuse pour qui reconnaît
avoir abattu cet hélicoptère russe et
s'excuse selon vous donc ça pourrait
être un rien à voir avec les combats
dans le haut-karabagh c'est un dommage
collatéral peut-être alors c'est quand
même très étonnant parce que précisément
c'est très étonnant précisément genou
répond à chaud je n'ai pas fait des
analyses mais c'est précisément ça n'a
pas eu du tout dans la zone de front ça
a eu lieu de l'autre côté sur l'autre
frontière arméno azéri à côté d'une
invite chez van et donc ça veut sas
s'assigne peut-être que l'azerbaïdjan
avait l'intention d'ouvrir un second
front
fois ci contre l'arménie âprement dit
est donc le karabagh comme d'ailleurs
l'ont laissé entendre à plusieurs
reprises divers responsables
azerbaïdjanais
donc ça serait très grave ça veut dire
que peut-être qu'ils ont c'est qui les
rend effectivement mais c'est quand même
très significatif de l'état de tension
et des menaces que fait peser désherber
de gentil je vous rappelle quand même
une dictature
je veux dire si les classements
internationaux c'est quand même une
dictature c'était quand même une menace
régionale et on attendra but on va quand
même attendre d'en savoir un peu plus
sur cet incident et ses liens présumés
donc avec ce qui se passe dans le
haut-karabagh s'agissant justement d'une
sortie au conflit et de médiation le
rôle des médiations étrangères
quelle est votre analyse pour l'instant
les médiations garde une position
d'équilibré qui est difficilement
compréhensible parce que les la
communauté internationale c'est
intervenir connais les populations en
danger on l'a vu avec saddam hussein en
irak
on l'a vu avec kadhafi en libye ou au
kosovo le gallo donc il ya cette fameuse
responsabilité de protéger qui devraient
ainsi peser comme je vous dis là vous
avez des populations qui sont menacés de
mort c'est pas simplement une guerre et
donc devrait intervenir
elles ne le font pas parce que parce
qu'il ya des considérations économiques
sans doute avec les arbitres jean et
puis parce qu'elle gens ne regardent un
peu ailleurs avec le co vide avec les
élections américaines
avec aussi une certaine importance de
l'union européenne
mais je crois que si demain nous
n'arrivons pas à monsieur alief derrière
lui comme vous savez monsieur erdogan
est bien ceci surtout sentir conforté ce
n'est pas que le cas du karabagh qui est
en cause c'est que demain est bien à
concilier des noirs en libye pourquoi
pas après demain dans les balkans le
maire de gan commencera à revendiquer
des places comme il l'a fait d'ailleurs
récemment il ya un mois ils
revendiquaient le jérusalem
si on arrête pas aux canards de misrata
pour jérusalem ou à vienne
merci à vous alors en laye cannes jean
d'avoir été en direct avec nous je
rappelle que vous êtes analyste
politique spécialiste de l'asie
une heure et du caucase